françoise mallet joris bonsoir alors
avant de parler du bouquin votre votre
vrai nom votre nom c'est lille art
pourquoi avoir choisi malevé parce qu'on
trouvait que c'était un autre ers mon
premier éditeur trouvé que c'était un
homme très répandue est que ça ne
laisserai personne
et puis ça quand même vexé quelqu'un
soit avec la lance une malle et voilà et
enfin disons que ça l'a un peu embêté et
puis on ajoute et joris qui est un nom
qui en belgique en flandre est aussi
répandues que mal est enfin joris est un
prénom flamand en fait voilà c'est ça
ces charges très bien oui d'accord alors
sept démons dans la ville chez plon
c'est votre combientième livre je crois
que c'est le 26e 26e alors françois
nourissier parlant il sait quoi oui non
monsieur justement je savais pas j'avais
lu diverses
alors françois nourissier dit dans le
figaro magazine que c'est le meilleur
j'en sais rien je je je n'ai pas lu
suffisamment pour dire que c'est le
meilleur en tout les cas il est bon si
votre copain nourricière c'était
l'académie goncourt avec lui non oui oui
vous avez été élu à l'académie goncourt
vais remplacer mac orlan c'est ça non
oui il ya déjà plus de 25 ans y en a
presque 30 ans a dit moi en 98 la wii
vous avez voté pour vous et soutenu
houellebecq paul constance du titre quel
côté paul constans
au bout d'un moment houellebecq hoebeke
n'était pas venu dans la dernière dans
le dernier vote puisqu'il n'avait pas
été sélectionné sur la dernière
sélection donc à ce moment là on ne vote
que très acceptions de conjoncture est
rude on va tous ceux qui naissent mais
le bouquin houellebecq vous trouvez ça
important où je trouve que c'est
délicieusement désuet ah bon ah bah
quand on pense qu'orange mécanique 7 72
d'accord bonfoh avait pas là pour parler
de lui enfin alors ses démons dans la
ville dont l'histoire jugeant dit deux
mots parce que toute façon va pas
raconter le bouquin disons qu'on est en
août 96 ya une dame s'appelle alex
et roche qui va à bruxelles avec sa
fille à bruxelles avec sa fille ève lyne
aux obsèques de son mari est parti à 10
ans et qui s'appelle maurice
on note au passage qu'evelyne la fille
est anorexique depuis le départ du père
donc et au même moment la belgique
découvre enfin vous parlez jamais du
trou dans votre bouquin enfin découvre
les affaires de pédophilie qui l'ont
secouée et à ce moment-là evelyne qui
avait refusé d'assister aux obsèques de
son père décide d'aller assister aux
funérailles de deux petites filles qui
ont été qui ont été tuées voilà donc ça
s'inscrit dans cet univers-là ça raconte
pas la sphère du trou enfin ça s'inscrit
là dedans je dirais que ça raconte la
réverbération le rôle de révélateur que
cette affaire a joué pour toute la
belgique pour moi même et pour mes
personnages et vous dites de leur page
122 parce que c'est vrai que c'était le
plus grave de tous tout était connue
rien n'a été évité alors bon ça c'était
un titre des jeunes à oui ça c'est le
tableau général mais on découvre
évidemment ça c'est le roman que maurice
était parti le père donc était parti
avec une dénommée julia qui avait 24 ans
mais quand on ouvre le testament on
s'aperçoit que il avait déjà une
relation avec elle depuis une dizaine
d'années ce qui fait 14 ans voilà donc
sa cellule alors je sais pas ce qu on
peut rajouter parce qu'après on peut
dire quand même que cette ce drame
épouvantable a révélé chez chacun des
choses différentes
evelyne qui à 23 ans c'est à dire
qu'elle a exactement l'âge de la
maîtresse de son père elle était un peu
gerritsen ans à kci et puis elle
s'identifie aux fillettes victimes de ce
drame et remonte en elle tout un passé
qu'elle avait occulté et où elle
s'interroge tout de même sur ses
relations avec son père qu'il a quitté
quand elle avait 12 ans tu es au
contraire qui est un peu longue plus
elle enquête qui est un ami intime de
maurice se demande s'il est possible que
cet homme qui avait l'air d'un
industriel je dirais même volontairement
banal et tuent tout le temps une double
vie de pensée étrange une perversité
d'ailleurs plus intellectuel que
physique
et s'interrogent comme en cent n'est-il
pas aperçu est ce que cette indifférence
au fond qui l'a porté à son ami ce n'est
pas l'indifférence que tout le monde a
eu au moment de la disparition des
enfants alors en préparant votre
interview j'ai découvert finalement vous
étiez assez c'est une histoire
finalement qui est beaucoup plus proche
de vous que ce qu'on pourrait le croire
parce que bon on pourrait penser que ses
proches de vous parce que vous êtes
belle je faisais la double nationalité
vous êtes d'origine flamande double
nationalité mais on s'aperçoit et on va
en parler que votre père
donc c'était le ministre mise la justice
et en belgique s'appelait albert lee
l'art c'est un grand homme politique
haute bourgeoisie anversoise c'est ça si
on veut son père est étonné élevé
willett voit la sfl lui même chef et lui
même c'est très bien fait et maman il
vole votre mère c'est quelqu'un en fait
maintenant on a un peu oublié enfin
susan lee l'art c'était quelqu'un de
très connu
c'est un femme de lettres 1 alors on va
me parler après mais disons qu'il ya une
chose qu'on sait encore moins c'est
qu'elle a écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle
la confession anonyme sous un pseudo un
lycée frère qui raconte ses amours avec
un italien
séduisant et quand on a découvert que
c'était votre mère ça fait un petit
scandale en belgique puisque c'était la
femme du ministre il a oui oui
certainement elle avait publié du reste
sous un pseudonyme dans l'idée de ne pas
gêner mon père qui était au ministère à
ce moment là mais ça n'a pas marché très
longtemps a très bien marché alors il
faut dire au passage qu'on en a fait un
film avec ses delvaux commun avec
gassman et vittorio gassman et fanny
ardant voilà alors votre maire là c'est
là on en arrive à vous votre mère a
écrit une pièce qui s'appelait le
burlats d'or le burlats dorst une sorte
de domjean un oui c'est une version
dédain cela qui était monté à hébertot
ce but-là d'or et je sais pas s'il était
metteur en scène louis ducreux mais il
vous a vu vous aviez quoi 17 ans du 7
ans et demi on m'aime pas je crois que
j'avais 16 ans allez vous enlevez oui
après diverses péripéties je savais pas
tous à temps des promesses est pressé de
faire tous les jeunes non mais bien sûr
que c'était régionaux de l'époque c'est
bien entendu là que je vais retrouver
oui mais dans les journaux de jours ma
femme tienne
chaque fois qu'on parle de françoise
mallet joris est toujours eu oui elle
est pratiquante et ya rien de mal à ça
enfin disons chrétienne pratiquante
ça ne veut dire c'est que voter
l'académie goncourt tout ça quand on
fouille un peu servir à l'académie
goncourt c'est pas un brevet de vertu
mais on va vous avez quand même défrayé
la chronique
donc votre père a porté plainte et à
l'encontre du creux oui non mais c est
alors qu il nous est facile et
l'histoire n'est pas finie vous le savez
bien
votre père porte plainte contre du creux
qui est addictive comme une grosse
différence d'âge donc l âge il avait du
creux à l'époque quand on s'est connu
moi j'avais 16 ans il devait en avant 35
avec quand même une bonne vingtaine
d'années
donc on nous envoie aux états unis aux
états unis vous on vous épousez à
monsieur amadou qui était professeur de
français c'est pas le jean amadou qu'on
connaît non non non
d'accord et est donc mais pendant le
voyage de noces vous retrouvez du creux
comme chez quelqu'un vous savez il
faudrait des heures pour que je vous
raconte tout ça non mais ça a été une
très belle période
ouais animée donc vous avez commencé à
écrire à 9 ans non c'était un peu
prématuré là quand même à 12 à 12 ans
j'ai fait un petit bouquin 12 un petit
remontant
j'ai fait des tas de roman à partir de
l'âge de leur voyage avaient arrêté
depuis
oui mais vous le voulez il est en vente
ce bouquin sorti quand même puisqu'on
dit le voyage à personne mais je ne sais
pas s'ils ont connu le titre peut-être
maman l'a raconté un jour mais j'ai
écrit des des romans pendant la guerre
de 40 sur les difficultés du
ravitaillement sur les vertus héroïques
de ma mère puis après je suis passé par
une phase jules verne
alors c'était les amours des
scaphandriers et ensuite je me suis mis
à écrire des poèmes et là on les a
public justement à 15 on le prévoit la
loi voilà et depuis j'ai pas arrêté
alors à 19 ans simone 10 mais bon là
c'est le scandale quoi enfin le scandale
c'est le succès de scandale à la fois
moi je m'en souviens j'étais pourtant ma
mère l'avait ce bouquin à quoi je dis
donc ça s'appelle laurent par des
béguines si vous l'avez pas lu il faut
le lire quand même parce que c'est un
classique
oui mais c'est un rallye aujourd'hui
vous ma voreque vu tout ce qui a eu
depuis ça ne paraît pas tellement
scandaleux mais je trouve bien rapport
vous me citez le rempart des béguines
qui est tellement vieux il ya un rapport
de thèmes sinon d'exécution entre le
rempart des bédié n'est cette démo dans
la ville parce que et on n'a pas
tellement mille axe
on l'a fait mais c'est pas le rapport de
femmes c'est le rapport d'un adulte et
d'un enfant vous donnera par jean faut
dire que nos amis qui n'ont pas lu
c'était comme on disait publiquement à
l'époque un roman sur lesbos on disait à
l'époque on parlait de base n'était pas
ici c'était quand même une femme d'un
certain âge dans la maturité et un
enfant de 14 ans donc il y avait quelque
chose oui c'est pour ça que je
commençais adultes enfants et toujours
basé sur des choses de pouvoir qui sont
assez maléfique alors en 58 du le prix
femina pour l' empire céleste alors là
aussi vous êtes battus quand on voit
qu'ils avaient contre vous à l'époque et
comme des bons bouquins parce que vous
l'avez eue pour l'empiré céleste contre
vous y avez christiane rochefort qui
publiait le repos du guerrier et
marguerite duras mode et cette entame à
un avoué pas aller ça te dit kirwa jeudi
ce qu'on en fin la maison de papier j'ai
fait des chansons aussi pour votre ami
d'état marie paule belle étape vous êtes
toujours là il avait pu la petite
capsule de coca cola autour du cou
qu'elles n'ont jamais permis à un moment
où j'ai eu beaucoup d'ennuis je me suis
dit que peut-être elle portait pas
vraiment bonheur alors vous est rangé
des voitures là maintenant vous êtes
sages
vous savez j'ai 68 ans ça se voit pas
tellement non c'est vrai non mais non je
suis pas j'ai jamais été ni dissiper à
l'intérieur ni tellement sage que ça je
crois que je suis simplement peu à côté
voilà alors vous êtes converti et vous
dit une chose certaine 3way 22 23 ans
oui vite sans dieu l'absurdité du monde
n'est pas soutenable
menem avec aimerait bonne phrase alors
vous êtes vraiment vous avez un paquet
l'accident quelle maladie vous avez aimé
vous êtes et vous étiez dans le coma et
vous avez vécu une expérience de mire
des expériences c'est à dire que vous
avez été quittée en bas d'un escalier
voyez les urnes funéraires oui en effet
oui oui en effet et je me suis souvenu
après j'étais à l'hôpital j'étais à
moitié dans le comminges entendait les
voix des des médecins mais en même temps
j'étais en train de monter un escalier
encadrait dure neuf unis
rere égyptienne avec la tête d'anubis et
j'allais vers une chose lumineuse et
j'étais toujours dans cet état
inqualifiable furieuse contre ces voix
de médecins qui essayait de me faire
redescendre et vous serez une expérience
reccueilli c'est ce qu'il aurait été
agréable de ce qui vous laisse partir à
ce moment qu'elle croyait
ouais ça me semblait donc la mort vous
quand vous avez vu la mort en face ça
vous a pas fait peur c'était comme une
lumière vous étiez déjà convertis je
dirais oui vous dites je suis d'une
extravagance paisible c'est ça qui vous
résume le mieux me construis mes parents
étaient comme savons qu'ils avaient une
apparence nuit d'être ministre il n'a
pas toujours été ministre mais enfin et
maman d'être une femme presque une femme
du monde un peu et pourtant il était
d'une originalité d'une bizarrerie maman
nous lisait toujours ma soeur est à moi
plotin à 7 heures du matin en nous
faisant manger de la soupe plutôt que du
café parce que c'était plus nous et sans
filet quand elle nous avait lu plotin et
qu'on avait discuté alors demandait de
lui résumer dallas parce qu'elle le
suive est qu'elle avait manqué un
épisode a les textes souvent le dit
souvent dans cette émission
contrairement à beaucoup de français qui
ont toujours une espèce de d'esprit de
supériorité par rapport aux belges nous
on se rend compte que finalement les
gens les plus fous viennent de flandre
viennent de belgique n'y a pas une
espèce d'originalité j'ai si bien si
l'on regarde les gens qui nous font rire
ils sont qui sont provocateurs
aujourd'hui souvent ils viennent de
là-bas mais c'est quand même une
tradition brogélienne finale où il ya un
grand calme apparent même une sorte de
nos mollets s'apparente et puis tout
d'un coup les gens se secouer fond des
choses hamas en fait comme vous donc
puisque j'ai découvrir tout ça donc je
rappelle le titre du livre s'appelle
sept démons dans la ville françoise
mallet joris chez plon c'est un vrai
roman voilà mais c'est très efficace en
tout cas merci beaucoup françoise à
bientôt
bonsoir enki bilal alors vous avez six
en tous les cas moi je disais tout à
l'heure quand c'était but en 89 augure
aussi que pour le film on s'est vus pour
le film
je dis pas vous n'avez rien fait depuis
six ans mais enfin vous avez rien publié
depuis 1993 froid équateur qui avaient
été choisis et lus par le magazine lire
comme le meilleur livre de l'année
toutes catégories confondues c'est à
dire pas dans le domaine de la bd donc
c'était assez important je vous demande
pas de répondre c'est juste pour dire
les choses quand même vous avez fait
quoi pendant pendant six ans j'ai quand
même passé deux ans à faire l'album donc
on va parler aujourd'hui c'est le
sommeil du monstre
j'ai fait un film dont celui avec
richard gaud bounty commune avec julie
des non non non j'ai envie d'un an
atteignant fin membres marie laforêt
piccoli j'ai fait aussi un autre livre
pas une bande dessinée un livre qui est
sorti en 94 s'appelle bleus semblent
sensées s'est passé pas un album c'est
comme les autres cd peinture la critique
des dessins sur calque et des petits
textes genre aphorismes et ou sur une
histoire de sensualité de
deux personnages qui me sont chères et
tout ça malheureusement déjà dans un
décor de guerre civile puisque la guerre
c'est ça non alors le sommeil du monstre
dont celui qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
qui est le premier d'une trilogie
donc c'est évidemment aux humanoïdes
associés c'est bon sur le plan formel si
vous êtes passés de la page avant votre
lit page par page maintenant c'est
carrément case par case
et puis chaque dessin est traitée comme
une peinture c'est pas par rapport à ce
que vous avez fait ça va encore plus
loin quand je dis pas que c'est nouveau
mais ça va plus loin
ça va plus loin peut-être mais c'est
plus plus plus rapide d'une certaine
façon il ya plus d'énergie c'est plus
des du mouvement de l'énergie dans le
dans le geste
donc c'est pour aller peut-être plus
vite et plus plus dans l'essentiel du
récit donc bizarrement le dessin devient
presque un instrument de l'écrit c'est
vraiment ces déchets ont été tout ça par
ordinateur sur vous ça vous scannez vos
dessins qui vous fait des montages de
passe et la violence du cinéma ça le
montage oui certainement
j'ai tous mes plus de liberté là dedans
alors bizarre mon cinéma on n'a pas
forcément de beaucoup de liberté parce
qu'il faut voir les plans à sa
disposition pour pouvoir faire du
montage et s'amuser au montage mais on
n'a pas toujours le temps de faire des
plans là en tout cas je peux les choisir
il avoue travailler debout maintenant
pourquoi pas ce qui nous attend mais non
non moi j'ai vu henri troyat qu'écrit
debout comme ça devant un lutrin et nous
mais je pense non en fait je me suis
rendu compte à un moment c'est en voyant
mon siège habituel habituellement vide
afin de tout objet puisque je me à soi
même si à un moment couvert de bouquins
de documentation et en fait c'est à ce
moment je me suis rendu compte que je
travaillais debout que je m'asseyais
plus pourquoi parce que le bras
simplement bouger le geste la wii le
geste rituel voilà c'est tout simple
mais en même temps donc j'ai dû relever
ma table enfin bon bref
mais c'est une chose très naturel a
drôlement et vous le savez c'est de la
peinture maintenance longtemps mais
lassant élise desaulniers narration
quant à l'or il ya un truc en voulant un
peu reproché mais voilà pour vous a dit
c'est un peu y aller il ya des voitures
volantes comme dans le cinquième élément
luc besson vous vous dites d'abord ce
n'est pas besson sénat jean claude
mézières
d'une part une page est fait voler avec
christain il ya plus de 15 ans ont un
village dans la croisière des doubles et
donc qui fait voler un village peut
faire voler un taxi
alors dans le fond c'est la première
fois où parler de la yougoslavie donc
pourquoi avoir attendu si longtemps pour
parler de votre pays puisque vous êtes
bosniaque musulman laïc donc c'est votre
pays et cela les jeux c'est parce que je
suis fait je le dis maintenant parce que
mon père les ténèbres et cheikh
morvillars et donc tout ça je sais pas
ce que je vous reçois avoir attendu
aussi longtemps pour parler de la
yougoslavie était un peu bas j'étais
j'étais sous le choc quand même c'était
extrêmement violent et puis il fallait
j'avais besoin quand même de me détacher
un peu de de l'impact journalistique je
dire je voulais pas faire un bouquin de
journaliste je voulais pas montrer la
violence la guerre je voulais l'évoqué
autrement donc il fallait que la lâche
la chose se cicatrisent un peu si elle
peut se cicatriser ce que je ne crois
pas parce que c'est très violent et ce
n'est pas fini la preuve
voir votre héros s'appelle nike hatzfeld
alors nike bas à cause des chaussures
parce qu'on a c'est les chaussures que
portait le mort qui était son père porte
tous les combattants mais je compte
mauvaise image à kaboul au rwanda ou en
bosnie on voit toujours d après un
attentat en votre jour une paire de nike
une chaussure nike qui traîne dans un
coin par pudeur de caméraman ne va pas
filmer le mort me filme la chaussure et
hatzfeld s'aidant d'un journaliste de
libération jean hatzfeld qui a fait pas
mal de papiers c'est un journaliste que
je connais mais c'est un mec formidable
surtout cintres est un très bon écrivain
également hélas son rapport à ce conflit
a été très sérieux et très impliqué
alors l'histoire haine qui en deux mots
quoi je veux dire ça se passe en 2026
en deux mots en 2026 un personnage qui a
une mémoire phénoménale c'est son métier
il en vit très bien se souvient qu'à j18
de sa vie donc chose tout à fait
impossible on ne peut pas imaginer ça il
se souvient ce manga 18 jour de sa
naissance
oui dix huit jours après sa naissance à
celle inverse de l'amnésie c'est ali
terminesi l'on perd mais il se souvient
de tout sur ses 18 premiers jours sûr
qu'il va y arriver parce qu'il est au
moment où démarre l'histoire il y est
arrivé à j18 donc après ses 17 16 et au
bouquin va dans ce sens donc en fait il
se souvient à ce moment là qu'il avait
deux orphelins à ses côtés également à
peine un ou deux jours de moins que lui
il est l'aîné et ce jour là ils se
décident ils se jurent en fait de les
protéger donc comment les retrouver en
fait une espèce de quête il essaie de
retrouver ces deux orphelins donc il
connaît pas l'identité et à travers son
son voyage mémorielle à compte à rebours
en fait il en évoque il évoque par les
mots uniquement par des mots de papa pas
une seule image
le conflit yougoslave donc ça c'est la
réalité de sa mémoire
c'est son retour en arrière mais il ya
également une réalité qui est présente
qui est celle de l'année 2026 et la
houle house et les effets pervers je
dirais espèce de néhou à l'ayatollah il
ya une secte fondamentalistes
intégristes
c'est une parabole mais enfin ça a très
loin de la réalité dans laquelle on vit
malheureusement pas très loin non
effectivement donc c'est ça le but
d'essayer de faire un effet de miroir
inversé de notre futur qui nous renvoie
une image dangereuse alors vous appeler
anne qui votre vrai nom cns votre vrai
prénom clsc papen qui sait pas plus
court en général en effet un diminutif
fondées sur nos pensées ben non c'est
mes parents qui m'ont appelé donc
j'avais quand j'avais si je me souviens
bien moment de mémoire ne va pas jusqu'à
j18 les non moins un ou deux trois ans
dans ma peine qui digèrent donc fait
rester comme ça à la une qui d'ailleurs
c'est l'anagramme de nike
oui justement bien sur wii hazard hasard
alors vous avez vécu de 51 à 61 à
belgrade
vous étiez pionniers quand vous étiez
petit comme tous les comme tous les
gamins gamines
vous aviez un foulard rouge autour du
cou vous en garder un bon souvenir non
ah oui c'était bien non ce n'est pas
l'armé ça sortait de l'école on avait
alors en face de chez vous il y avait un
musée en plein air avec des avions et
des chars de la 2ème guerre mondiale et
sur les mieux élevés les impacts de
balle hors canton c'est ça quand on sait
où vous avez été élevé en face de ces
espèces de carcasses de chars d'assaut
et d'avions et qu'en plus de ça vous
lisez des journaux dans lesquels il y
avait indiqué donald les cowboys les
indiens parce que la yougoslavie de tito
c'était pas la russie de staline
on voit très bien d'où est venu le vous
vient l'inspiration de bilal parce que
d'un côté il ya la bande dessinée donc
le walt disney tout ça et puis de
l'autre côté il ya cette espèce de
dégénérescence et de mémoire tito il a
en fait c'était ça à tous toutes sont
tout son pouvoir était basé sur le
devoir de mémoire imposer la banque ce
qui en soi n'est peut-être pas une
mauvaise chose et c'est de là que ça
vient vous avez déclaré un truc qui m'a
toujours si vous avez dit jeu quand
cerisier longtemps que ça faisait dix
jeux quand series la réalité mais c'est
ça finalement oui c'est ça fait peur un
mot comme ça un essai oui oui c'est une
façon de la gérer au jour d'aujourd'hui
je ferais autrement je dirais peut-être
que j'ai c'est de là
comment dire de me l'approprier et de
l'art de la charge et l'a chargé
d'histoire de vécu finalement la réalité
c'est beau à mener c'est beau quand elle
est dense
j'aime bien les choses dense touffu
c'est dans ce sens alors votre père
était résistant pendant la guerre et
ensuite il est bon il était tailleur
il a dans les faits le tailleur de tito
mais il n'a jamais voulu rentrer au pc
et c'est pour ça qu'il est parti c'est
pour ça qu'il est parti il est parti
donc il est venu à paris viennent avant
vous il est venu à paris de 9 ans avant
vous est venu nous absolument est il là
où il y avait ça il y avait ce côté là
il y avait un orgueil si c'est un
personnage atypique et mon père il est
il à il rêvait d'amérique
enfin bon c'était un peu ce les balkans
produisent toujours des gens comme ça et
là mais en france on fait son idée c'est
dans l'amérique alors quand il est parti
ou quand vous êtes parti vous avez
échangé la part le visa contre un
appartement sur vous a laissé sortir à
condition à condition de laisser
l'appartement où on allait damman deux
doigts de le donner c'était pas une
vision de propriété mais tout simplement
de faire passer les gens rebond avant
avant d'autres alors une question je
vais vous poser votre père est mort
malheureusement il ya un an et demi il
s'est un petit peu laissé laisser partir
les cdc mourir et vous dit sans pouvoir
faire comprendre aux gens ce qui se
passait dans son pays
à votre avis qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
est ce qui voulait dire parce que là
vous êtes je dirais que vous avez vous
êtes en situation de le dire vous un peu
non je pense pas qu'il est je crois que
lui-même était perdue à ce moment là
c'est peut-être au moment où il a perdu
tout on dira toute relation avec
une réalité déjà très fantasmé parce que
le conflit pour lui ça devenait quelque
chose d'assez incroyable un jour il
disait une chose le lendemain une autre
c'était très très confus donc je crois
qu'il a peut-être je pense pas qu'il
soit mort de samy les moeurs de plein de
choses mais finalement d'une espèce de
renoncement à ces nobles un peu qui
ressemblerait presque au celui d'un des
personnages de l'album review
enfin je veux dire la partie terminesi
la maternité de sarajevo on voit bien
quand on lit votre bouquin de toute
façon tout ça parle de vous et comme
tous les bons auteurs disent bon alors
là c'est péché repasser au cinéma donc
et le bunker palace hotel en avait parlé
il ya neuf ans il ya eu tykho moon avec
julie delpy n'avait pas été tendre avec
les critiques
quelle mafia ces critiques n'ont la dame
fait allusion à un papier dans les
inrocks qui avait un peu caricatural
caricatural sur la retranscription en
tout cas de certains de mes propos qui
me dans ce papier d'ailleurs j'attaque
même godard godard je touche jamais un
jeu de godard parce que je m'aime comme
ça m'ennuie je trouve les critiques
qu'ils aiment bien le film tchétchène et
même le film de godard comme un modèle
du genre non godard non si pour moi
c'est un modèle du genre donc et puis
même mon producteur et mal cité avec
faux noms les critiques le problème
c'est que les critiques ont rejeté le
film je trouve un sens le critique et
moi j'aurais aimé la critique j'adore la
critique quand elle est argumentée tout
va bien mais ce film n'a pas été vue n'a
pas été rejetée simplement parce que je
ne vous dites vous même ce film il faut
le voir trois fois et après c'est
limpide
vous dites riches de 10,2 fois ce qu'ils
aiment pas d'ailleurs enfin non c'est
vrai c'est anti commercial c'est vrai
voilà c'est comme les bouquins il faut
les lire de trois fois mais non non mais
ça j'assume ce film et j'admets
parfaitement qu'on n'aime pas que les
gens ne viennent pas ou qu'il n'ait pas
envie de voir ce jeu puis la critique
mais qu'elle fasse son travail et ne
rejette pas d'emblée parce que ça vient
d'un monde
n'est pas noble ne rangez senti ça dans
certains papiers la dernière question
est-ce que vous avez été victime comme
kusturica finalement dans les médias
français de votre position ou d'aucune
position par rapport à par rapport au
conflit yougoslave lui la naïma un
moment il avait même et voiliers mais il
a parlé directement dans under ground de
la ville excuse moi tu commune ça parle
de la fin d'une dictature d'un certain
type de dictature alors c'est vrai que
si on revoit le film il faut aussi on le
voit on peut comprendre que peut-être
que 1000 de chez fitch a quelque chose à
voir avec le piccoli de mon fils mais là
il ya quelque chose d'assez d'assez
impressionnant
je vais montrer à belgrade de filmer les
gens ils m'ont dit mais c'est un film
sur nous oui tamino ceviche pas votre
ami
pas du tout non non il ya là aussi une
rue menant la vie à une rumeur qu'il
faut en va en profiter pour l'amant la
folie tordent le cou ça c'était au
lutétia en 96 et un auteur qui s'appelle
hermann qui a fait jeremiah et comanche
et qui était là mais gâché un bouquin
sur sarajevo tombeau prédit il y avait
des hatchuel charts hedberg enfin tout
ce genre de personnage et et m'a dit je
suis déçu par bilal il est l'ami de
milosevic
alors pour vous c'est terrible parce que
d'abord c'est pas vrai et louane et là
apparemment j'ai jamais vu ce mec là je
n'en tiens pas nous qui a été obligé
l'éditeur de harman dupuis est obligé de
vous faire des excuses et vous avez
déclaré d'ailleurs karman est un grand
irresponsable doublé d'un grand con
toujours les mêmes sources la récup they
will responsable grands comptes j'en
sais rien je ne connais très peu
nancy responsable de balancer des gens
aiment ça c'est un sujet tellement grave
c'est tellement violent c'est tellement
sadi a tellement de morts autour de ça
c'est pas la peine de danger de tomber
dans l'approximatif surtout que je ne
suis pas serbes et d'autres par la suite
quand je dis je suis belgradois c'est
mal pris alors c'est magique parisien
sur ça veut pas dire qu'on est à mais
c'est mal pris ça fait mal pris en
bosnie parce qu'il faudrait maintenant
que je me détermine et je dise attendez
je suis tous les serbes sont des mômes
et relève ses taux avant la
tribalisation c'est la seule chance de
rester en dehors de ça et je sais que
les victimes c'est avec je pense d'abord
et je pense aux monstres qu'ils ont fait
ces victimes ces monstres ils sont
effectivement certes mais aussi des
monstres crois qu il ya même des
monstres musulman donc très bien merci
tibi là donc je rappelle le titre c'est
le sommeil du monstre c'est aux
humanoïdes associés et ça vaut le coup
merci beaucoup à bientôt
je reçois maintenant le comédien claude
piéplu pour son rôle dans astérix et
obélix contre césar et surtout ses
mémoires intitulées il faut croire aux
éléphants blancs publié aux éditions du
rocher
un livre dans lequel la voix des shadoks
qui fête cette année ses 50 ans de
carrière fait défiler en 200 pages
le film de sa vie claude piéplu bonsoir
vont souverain alors effectivement je
vous ai travaillé sur ce livre avec une
fille qui était venu vous interviewer
pour télérama qui s'appelle rouchy parce
que j'ai retrouvé le papier de télérama
et j'ai vu quand vous êtes connu en 95
j'en suis sûr parce que j'ai retrouvé le
papier alors c'est pas difficile de
bosser avec vous parce que vous gardez
tout vous gardez les coupures de
journaux vous gardez tout oui je ne suis
pas du tout je n'ai pas d'appareil photo
oui je suis pas quelqu'un qui prend des
photos à tout bout de champ qu'il a avec
son appareil parce que je trouve que ça
limite un petit peu le champ visuel
paradoxalement de pau d'avoir un
appareil de vouloir à tout prix prendre
une photo alors pour avoir quand même
des traces et des références grave et on
chez moi je note trois lignes où je
gagnais rsa sans est là qu il ya plein
de détails en plus vers les lettres que
vous avez envoyé aux gens les réponses
qui vous ont fait ou pas fait de lui un
jour vous avez envoyé une lettre chez
pas sur quoi
giscard vous a répondu langue vous a
répondu le chef qui vous a pas répondu
c'est roland dumas voilà unis devaient
être avec christine deviers-joncour huit
versions beaucoup à faire et à voir mon
groupe à faire collectionnez les pots de
chambre
oui et vous collectionnez aussi les
bourdelle ou dites-nous ce que c'est un
bordel où il aura fait quelque chose
c'est un bourdaloue ces sites à pot de
chambre en fait c'est six étapes autre
chose qu'à la forme d'une sociale etc
les dames qui allaient écouté
monseigneur bourdaloue grands
prédicateurs du xviie siècle et j'aurais
tellement longtemps là pour ne pas
perdre une goutte des paroles du grand
prédicateur quand elle avait un besoin
naturel et pressent au lieu de se
déplacer est l'axé là où elle était elle
le bordel où étaient sous les jupes et
là les choses se passaient voilà alors
votre livre c'est votre vie on peut dire
en quelle année vous êtes né quel âge
vous avez oui on peut tout dire mais en
1923 la même année que le prince de
monaco
bah oui ça vous fait quand même 76 ans a
fait 76 non oui j'y vais oui j'ai pas
encore rivés sur leur soif de bien
savoir où georges frêche changeait pas
nous avons dans ce bouquin vous raconter
votre vie d'une façon effectivement très
précise alors votre père était cuisinier
il travaillait chez potain chez le père
de félix potager je viens potins vos
paroles je vous raconte votre vie comme
ça oui le neveu de 6 2 je raconte votre
vie comme ça parce que sinon ça bon donc
vos parents divorcent vous ça vous
laisse effectivement une certaine
indépendance donc c'est plutôt pas mal
pour un bien finalement
et alors là vous prenez conscience de
votre vocation dans la rue en voyant les
camelots quoi c'est ça a été votre wii
en étant spectateurs de tout ce qu'il ya
dans la rue la rue était une rue très
très très vivante et la rude montée
suisse marcel wyss était l'invité la rue
des gens de maison parce qu'à l'époque
il y avait des rues comme ça par
corporation
oui parce qu'il se dit des tuyaux et les
maîtres d'hôtel les chauffeurs de m bien
sûr très épais vous avez un petit
appartement quelque part où on pouvait y
lire votre première école c'est la russe
et les camelots puis vous lisez un autre
jour on avait niels arestrup ici qui
disait quand il était petit dans son hlm
à montreuil il rêver en lisant ciné
revue vous c'était en lisant vedette
kate un journal encore plus antique que
ciné revue bon mais en même temps vous
épateront franchir le pas et vous il ya
un type seul monsieur françois qui vous
fait rentrer dans une banque créée ça
c'est ça oui oui en fait pour moi
j'avais envie d'être un artiste j'avais
envie d'être marty
uste et c'était à la limite de
l'abstraction mardi c'est ce que ça
existait vraiment est-ce que c'était pas
dans ma tête est ce que c'était des
personnages qui n'étaient pas comme
maintenant compte tellement fef familier
il y avait les médias ne l'ait présenté
pawel manière facile à la condition
d'artiste l'est beaucoup moins connue
que maintenant alors pour moi c'était un
monde à la limite de l'abstrait de
l'inaccessible me demander si ça
existait vraiment si ce n'était pas un
rêve de vouloir et inaccessible
impossible vous vous travaillez dans
cette banque pendant un moment ça vous
ça vous commencé dans la vie
professionnelle disant oui et puis
ensuite un jour quand même vous fait
mettre en congé maladie
et puis vous partez de cette banque
vernes qui pourtant vous avez reçue très
gentiment et vous vous lancez dans la
carrière et vous tombez c'est tombé sur
escande qui vous dit tu devrais jouer
les rôles à l'ajout vs que quand même un
encouragement formidable wissam assam
absolument se doper continuer ça j'ai
dit oh bah oui parce que je vais sauter
un peu comme ça oui oui bah ça c'était
mon côté un petit peu long un petit peu
et flanqué vide un peu de dégoût si des
restrictions de vous raconter vos débuts
et là on voit bien que c'est pas facile
quoi alors je vais vite bien sûr enfin
il ya une anecdote que vous racontez
avec jean louis barrault un jour vous
arrivez sur une scène puis vous devez
jouer un rôle
et puis vous découvrez qu'un autre type
à qui on donnerait j'avais j'avais
répété depuis déjà quelques jours un
rôle dans le procès - obtention du du
roman de kafka et j'avais un geste très
précis à faire que je répétais
consciencieusement depuis au moins 8 10
jours je devais m'adresser face au
public et je devais dire joseph k 1 est
à côté de moi il ya quelqu'un qui fait
joseph k je me retourne et je vois c'est
emile drunk aux médias qu on se regarde
et je lui fais un petit salut polis ils
étaient plus âgés que moi je recommence
joseph tahir fait joseph cas là il ya eu
un petit dialogue entre nous bonjour
bonjour je répète ma réplique que
monsieur barrowman pneumatiques et des
plus belles dit moi il me l'a il m'a
demandé de la dir
et hier ah bon et moi il m'a demandé de
la dir début juin et là vous découvrez
où il avoue découvrez le monde du
spectacle et pas toujours oui oui à
l'horizon d'une anecdote avec vilar
aussi quand vous avez joué le père
d'orphée et evilard vont tnp avignon et
c'est dans la cour d'une jouer dans la
cour du palais des papes et villard vous
dit écoutez moi j'ai jou eurydice
d'anouilh tous les soirs je peux pas
entendre ça voilà exactement moi c'était
pas vrai dit c'était roméo et jeannette
way et moi je lui avais passé une
audition d'anne ou oui oui vous venez
avec ce fétiche était le père d'en faire
jouer le soir pour villard anouilh et
entendre un jeune gars qui arrive pour
lui passer encore du fmi alors là il n'a
pas pu supporter alors là vous êtes
amené ça sert mais déjà après la guerre
vous êtes vous êtes embarqué dans un
truc qu'on ne sait même plus enfin les
gens les jeunes ne savent pas que ça
existait c'était le théâtre outre-mer
sert qu'à l'époque avait des colonies
donc vous partiez jouer dans le truc
c'est la france
il y avait la force d'outre-mer alors
vous partez joué dans toutes ses toutes
ses tournées comme ça c'est comme un peu
comme votre père finalement vous en
revenez un travail de saison vous vie
exacte et donc vous partez alors là
évidemment il ya toutes ces villes qui
font rêver à pondichéry tamatave
djibouti saigon et vous allez alors ce
qui fait un peu quand même dans votre
livre un peu frustrant c'est finalement
vous avez vu à ce moment là des choses
sûrement très pittoresque c'est clair et
finalement tout ce que vous semble en
retenir c'est je me dis pour la première
fois cette phrase qui devait revenir
sans arrêt si où sont passés nos bagages
serre que votre problème numéro un
salaire net parce que ça a commencé
comme ça vous fera cas je ne suivais pas
tout jouer et c'est vrai que c'était pas
un peu obsessionnel oui on n'avait
qu'une idée c'est de retrouver le navire
au bailliage c'est tout le matériel de
doué de seine luis équipe a tellement
nos bagages personnels vous raconter des
fois qu'ils manquent des manques des
projecteurs et manquent d'eau et laurent
75 vous décidez de devenir un militant
du théâtre vivant parce que vous dites
finalement le théâtre classique
c'est une satisfaction pour soi même
mais c'est une satisfaction d'interprète
et en fait vous vous avez eu à coeur
depuis l'époque de juin théâtre vivant
toujours le théâtre d'aujourd'hui c'est
ça d'être un petit peu d'entretenir ma
curiosité et mon envie de continuer on
annonce toujours un petit peu vers
l'inconnu
suscité en moi le besoin du découvrir le
plus bel exemple de ça ça sera les
diablogues avec roland dubillard alors
on en a pas beaucoup de temps mais dites
nous un peu parce que ceux du billard
avait l'air d'avoir une personnalité
absolument très fermé il était autiste
ce type là non c'était un personnage qui
se prenaient l'avion avait avec vous il
y avait avec lui disait rien bordeaux
d'ailleurs on ne se parlait pas on se
parlait vraiment aux répétitions pour
mettre au point les scènes mais encore
avec un minimum de mots et beaucoup de
précautions roland oui c'est rien que
vous ne pensez pas que si si je suis
jeune et décalée un tout petit peu sur
la gauche ce serait pas mieux du point
de vue angle de briguer à peine à peine
d'ailleurs drôle de personnage marqué
quand on voit les diablogues c'est vrai
que c'est très bizarre pour lui ça peut
avoir un mental assez spécial alors les
shadoks évidemment tout le monde vous
connaît à travers les shadoks alors ça
vous a l'air de vous embêter parce que
c'est vrai que vous avez fait quand même
pas mal de trucs c'est clair et alors on
sent un petit peu dit moi si je me
trompe mais on sent vous l'avez mis à la
fin du livre parce que l'éditeur a dû
vous dire écoutez pied plus vous êtes
gentils parlez-moi des shadoks parce
qu'on se sent que ça vous emmerde non
non je n'irai pas jusqu'au là parce
qu'on peut pas quand même quand on a
participé à quelque chose qui a réussi
qui a été un succès qui reste dans les
mémoires dont on se souvient absolument
très bien on peut pas on peut pas renier
ça et dire ils sont trop verts c'est
quand même agréable mais cela dit en
plus de 50 ans d'action les shadoks on
était nous a pas duré longtemps de 3 ans
3 4 ans maintenant c'est devenu en plus
les shadoks c'est devenu un classique
vous le savez rouxel c'était à hernani
quand c'est pas recommencer rouxel ça
fait un classique avec ça
alors ya eu là les chaussettes kindy qui
avait fait une publicité en utilisant
votre voix j'étais pas vous c'est
quelqu'un qui vous imiter et vous avez
obtenu sa fait jurisprudence c'est sa
voix et déposer maintenant mais voilà si
on veut si vous le savez le problème de
la propriété vocale si je puis 10 est
posée pour la première fois ils
n'étaient pas encore posé avant ça oui
alors vous parlez très peu de cinéma
parce que c'est vrai que vous avez de
jouer des pièces tellement
j'irai excellente que c'est difficile
mais je trouve qu'une certains présents
pour parler du gendarme de saint tropez
c'est rigolo le gendarme de saint tropez
oui mais on doit vous en parler plus en
parler un petit peu là aussi vous en
parler un peu comme de quelque chose de
subalternes mais moi j'ai une anecdote
qui est pas dans le bouquin mais que
vous avez raconté dans un
dans un article précédemment c'est le
journal de saint tropez au bout de la
deuxième prise avait le producteur
beytout qui disait toujours c'est bon
pour tous et pour tout le monde mais là
vous vous dites ça oui y avait il y
avait une voix qui arrivait une fois
cachés personne personne ne voyait d'où
ça venait ekombe tous voulaient pas
connu trop de pellicules et c'est pas
pour tout le monde et là le metteur en
scène et un jour j'ai découvert que
beytout disait sac derrière un arbre en
parle avec un copain puis quand il avait
entendu que c'est la deuxième crise
disait c'est bon pour tout le monde vous
pouvez tout est complètement de savoir
personne ne cherchait à savoir d'où ça
venait même le metteur en scène où elles
étaient habilités algéro non seulement
très ça alors ne cherchez pas la belle
américaine hibernatus qui sont des films
quand même qu'ils ont alors vous dans
votre bouquin vous parlez de merci
bernard vous parlez pas de palace outil
formidable dans le palace convié le
concierge
ah oui c'est formidable oui vous
acceptez cette lacune cela qu il
accueille un truc avant de nous séparer
je vous faire raconter c'est à dire que
vous avez pacifistes et antinucléaire
pacifiste vous avez jamais été au pc
mais on peut dire quand même vous avez
été un compagnon de route du parti
communiste qui déshabille oui vous ai
signé l'appel des 100 excellent terrain
et alors ce que je comprends pendant
votre livre c'est quand vous quand vous
parlez de l'époque de l'outre-mer
l'époque de vous faisiez ses tournées
dans les colonies françaises vous dites
là bas les gens nous prenaient pour des
stars on nous traitait comme des rois
et vous n'allez pas un mot pour les
indigènes c'est à dire comment on
pouvait vous à la fois militer pour la
protection de murs roi comme vous l'avez
fait en 95 quand chirac a recommencé les
essais et comment pendant toute cette
période vous passez andretti reçus comme
des princes imagine effectivement et à
aucun moment dans votre livre vous avez
un mot de compassion pour les pour ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque les indigènes
baiona compassion mon nom ma même
émission entre guillemets si je puis
dire est temps là bas c'était justement
de faire passer à ces indigènes entre
guillemets enfin qu'ils étaient les
habitants locaux
le message de nos politiques s'étaient
admis
nous représentons la foulée des records
faisait quand même des représentations
pour la jeunesse somalienne la jeunesse
africaine
d'ailleurs si vous souhaitez un certain
moment non livres pour démystifier un
tout petit peu les shadoks je commence
le chapitre dans voulait pas que je vous
parle un peu de bonheur auprès des
petits sauts mal mais c'est vrai c'est
quoi j'ai fait des courses et mal hier
c'était mon but lâche à écouter sert
elle s'est répandue ce qui est assez
drôle pour vous pouviez pas un pacifiste
et personnes nous le reprochera c'est
qu'en fait on vous a souvent donné des
rôles de militaires aussi
c'est assez paradoxal oui pour finir
vous parlez beaucoup de vous dites
beaucoup à votre mère vous avez mis en
garde et je pense que cette phrase a
quand même dû vous restez mon petit gars
cherche pas midi à quatorze heures pense
au mois qui tombe
oui c'est vrai que les mamans enfin dans
les milieux d'où on vient les les mamans
sont toujours du souci quand on embrasse
la carrière d'artiste et finalement est
ce que vous regrettez pas d'avoir été un
peu trop prudent parce que vous dites
aussi pourquoi noir et philippe noiret
c'est toujours le rôti et moi je suis
légumes vous dit j'avais rêvé d'une
carrière la règle harrison ou alec
guinness
vous regrettez pas finalement j'ai pris
beaucoup de risques à parler surtout à
29,75
vous regrettez pas finalement devoir
sauter plus haut plus un pas plus large
je dirais je je sais pas si je dois dire
que je regrette je peux regretter en
fait qu'on ne met pas utilisé comme je
pense que j'aurais pu l'être au cinéma
web j'entends au cinéma au théâtre g de
nîmes avec un petit peu et personnel
c'est vrai mais au cinéma et on vous
prend en main où on vous prend pas mais
pas question qu'un agent maintenant
peut-être c'est dû à ça peut-être c'est
dû à un agent qui n'a peut-être pas bien
bien organisée la chose mais c'est vrai
mais cela dit comme je dis ça m'a ça m'a
donné l'occasion d'aller ailleurs et
d'être ce ce ctt way comédiens tout
terrain ça c'est vrai qui après tout est
une chose qui restera en tous les cas
que le pied plus c'est le
la facilité de que vous donnez à des
jeunes dramaturges joie des jeunes
cinéastes est vous leur faites confiance
si vous avez fait beaucoup de premières
pièces beaucoup de premiers films et ça
c'était un beau cadeau que vous leur
faites en même temps oui oui mais ça ça
fait partie où vous venez fait de mon
goût de l'inconnu de l'aventuré du
voyage c'est un drôle de bonhomme et ses
décors étaient contents de vous avoir
donc je répète le titre du livre c'est
il faut croire aux éléphants blancs
parce que comme vous l'avez compris
claude piéplu croit l'utopie est
quelqu'un qui a un très grand coeur
merci beaucoup je reçois maintenant
andré dussollier pour son rôle dans les
enfants du marais le dernier long
métrage de jean becker attendu sur nos
écrans mercredi prochain dans la france
de l'après grande guerre une chronique
bucolique qui filme des amitiés viriles
et rurales ou un dussollier dandy et
mandat vient promener sa précieuse et
chaleureuse nonchalance bonsoir andré
dussollier donc les enfants du marais
film de jean becker adaptation et
dialogues du fameux sébastien japrisot
alors on va citer les autres acteurs
parce que comme une pléiade d'acteurs il
ya jacques gamblin
il ya jacques villeret que vous avez
connu au conservatoire et michel
serrault isabelle carré même eric
cantona qui se sort plutôt plutôt bien
très bien son rôle
alors c'est un film assez étrange parce
que c'est un film je dirais un peu
intemporel à une époque où il ya pu y
ait toujours deux trois homosexuels par
film ont alors il ya des extra
terrestres là il n'y a pas d'homosexuels
n'ya pas d'extraterrestres la livrée
spéciale pas d'effets spéciaux etc
la masse du muguet au début du film on
était très inattendu mais et quand on a
mis le pied en cinquante ans quand on
voit le film moi j'avais pas vu le film
tout entier avec mécènes pour cause je
sais pas on se laisse prendre par une
émotion ça raconte en effet l'amitié de
gens qui sont assez démunis qui n'ont
pas beaucoup de moyens et c'est vrai que
c'est une grande opposition avec ce
qu'on vit aujourd'hui avec on peut voir
au cinéma et ce qu'on vise à dire qu'on
est un peu dans les villes dans des
cités un peu robotisée et c est là au
contraire c'est vous parliez de
cruseilles tout à l'heure c'est un peu
ça me rappelle ce à quoi la campagne il
faut dire en gros sans raconter toute
l'histoire enfin il ya deux personnages
qui sont gambles
villeray qui vivent dans un marais près
à une grande ville enfin près du prêt
d'une ville de province
et puis bon bah gamblin il supporte un
peu villeray quand même un vrai bon à
rien dans cette ville il ya un
personnage que vous incarnez alors là
avec une drôlerie formida vous dites
vous dit toujours qu'on vous donne
jamais de à ces deux rôles de
composition rival personnages de la bd
c'est quand même un rôle de composition
c'est ce qui ma tante et mon rôle de
composition c'est un type maniéré un peu
célibataire un peu grosse et moment un
garçon à maire du mans et qui est très
très loin et de villerest gamblin qui
eux se débrouille pour vivre avec la
réalité et l huile est plutôt dans le
jazz ray de leurs bras des travaux alain
champs ou à des choses comme ça et vous
en faites vous voulez être copain avec
eux parce que vous vous les admirer un
petit peu parce qu'ils sont libres oui
je fais partie d'un milieu bourgeois qui
est un peu démuni aussi qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de moyens et donc il ya quelque
chose qui nous réunit tous éteints c'est
l'amitié la fraternité surtout la
possibilité de participer à des choses
entre elles au quel jeu dont j'étais un
peu détaché mais quelque chose qui se
dégage de de leur personnalité c'est
c'est ça qui est intéressant me semble
dans le film il ya aussi michel serrault
mais aussi qui a lui était dans les
marais à lui la fortune a déraillé puis
après mais tous ces personnages sont
dans des situations un petit peu
précaire 1 sauf michel serrault mais
enfin détroit dont on parle là et ils
sont obligés de se débrouiller par
eux-mêmes quoi avec
c'est comme si aujourd'hui on a le
progrès a fait qu'on a beaucoup de
moyens et qu'on oublie un petit peu
l'effort personnel alors là les forfaits
que toutes les choses ont de la valeur
est liée au sida solidarité entre les
gens pensent qu'on nous parle toute la
journée de solidarité à la télévision là
on voit bien la vraie solidarité enfin
gamblin on voit bien qu'il est venu là
après la guerre de 14 il reste là dans
ce marais uniquement parce qu'il faut
bien que s'il s'en aller villeray et sa
famille crèverait de faim donc il ya une
vraie solidarité qui réel fac et proche
des gens c'est pas des grandes phrases
la télé
c'est filmé de façon extrêmement simple
parce que les scènes se sont révélés
comme ça les unes après les autres et
l'émotion qui finit par se dégager
semble-t-il par dans cette histoire qui
est tout à fait en effet comme vous
l'avez dit très inattendu aujourd'hui
comme si c'était un compte rendu de ce
qui était avancé pas nostalgique moi
c'est pour dire qu'en cette fin de
siècle voilà c'était dans les années ben
oui alors on disait vous étiez donc de
cruseilles à fils unique vos parents de
travailler aux impôts au trésor public
comme elle dit alors vous avez découvert
le théâtre avec un prof de français qui
un jour vous à vous montrer poil de
carotte
vous avez vu sur scène poil de carotte
et vous avez été fasciné de voir que des
gens pouvait rire et pleurer sur scène
et que finalement il y en a qui paient
pour venir voir ça c'est une révélation
pour une révélation enfin c'est surtout
que tout d'un coup je voyais des gens en
effet laissé libre cours à leurs états
d'âme à leur sentiment qu'ils étaient
les acteurs et ça me donnait tout d'un
coup une ouverture par rapport à la vie
ou plutôt les choses étaient contre et
on est pas on peut pas toujours dire ce
qu'on veut dire ce qu'on pense faire ce
qu'on ressent et là tout d'un coup le
métier d'acteur m'ouvrait des horizons
que
vidéo l'ambiance un petit peu papa
confiné mais enfin c'est mon vin ciel
mercialys unis sanofi les relations
village la ville est restée la première
pièce de théâtre le premier film c'est
les 400 coups vous avez pas les 400
coups c'était une belle fille comme moi
de truffes alors ça ci dessus vous avez
fait messieurs vous avez vu c'est que
j'ai 4 censé nous aviez 12 13 ans non
mais parfois confiance fait d'ailleurs
on vous avait laissé le voir parce qu'il
a vu le prix de l'office catholique
oui bon alors vos parents vous voulez
faire ça voulait faire acteur puis vos
parents vous dise comme comme à beaucoup
d'enfants passe ton bac parce qu'un bac
d'abord et alors là vous êtes vachement
sérieux parce que vous allez à grenoble
et qu'est ce que vous faites comme et
dessus de ses études de linguistique et
de lettres modernes et je vais même
jusqu'au bout et au bout on me dit bon
d'accord la maintenant vous pouvez être
assistante philologie à la fac d'oranger
dit non merci et longue
non je ne suis jamais allé et puis
j'avais pas du tout envie de d'enseigner
la philologie je me sentais aucune
aptitude pour ça mais j'avais été au
goût de ses études j'aimais bien la
littérature mais j'avais toujours
parallèlement fait du théâtre est alors
en 69
c'est à nous de paris à vous débarquez à
paris les 23 ans et là c'est de sauter
le pas parce que dorée venant d'une
famille de fonctionnaires
vous devenez un saltimbanque prix parce
que ça fait un peu peur vu de la
province comme ça on sait pas quel est
ce milieu et cetera est bon
alors je me suis en effet j'ai fait mes
études et je me suis payé la liberté
avec ses diplômes l'a peut-être de faire
enfin ce que j'avais envie de faire du
théâtre
et donc j'ai débarqué à paris je mettais
un petit peu renseigné j'ai fait un
cursus normal quand je sais le groupe
riri money c'est un cours privé est un
c'est un monsieur qui s'appelle jean
périmony à qui je dois beaucoup et qui
est un procès la cua j'ai commencé là
j'ai la figuration un peu dans les faits
dim dam dom avec jugnot et après vous
rentrez leur a pris pour entrer au
conservatoire alors là vous rencontrez
vivrait donc c'est quand même marrant
c'est marrant quand même parce que tout
le monde est passé par là moi je m'en
rends compte en faisant ce boulot il y
avait vivrait il y avait berry al mère
nathalie baye est alors dans la classe
au dessus il y avait eu ce ter et webber
et dans la classe au dessous il y avait
zéro donc fait que malgré tout se
retrouver là alors si vous faites votre
premier film pendant que vous êtes au
conservatoire oui c'était avec françois
truffaut qui était venu voir un
spectacle monté par speisser qui
s'appelait léon 0 exactement du snes et
alors bon j'ai eu la chance d'être
engagé par lui mais dans un rôle un peu
particulier déjà une composition parce
que c'était l'époque où triomphait les
dustin hoffman et oui il convoyait se
métamorphoser d'arrosage
vous vouliez absolument faire des rôles
de composition amusé c'est ça qui
m'amusait puis je me disais bien alors
après non ça m'a coincé un peu cette
image parce que on n'a pas vu c'est la
première image qui va reparler de votre
image justement c'est à dire
qu'effectivement là vous avez aussi les
coincer vous aviez des lunettes
originaire des gants jaunes introverti
un peu maladroit et à la bi je me
faisais manipulé par planet la frank
était en prison bref et ça m'a poursuivi
un peu ma poche grâce à nina companeez à
la télévision qui m'avait vu au
conservatoire passer des comédies puis
ensuite grâce à deux louches aussi après
j'ai retrouvé un rôle plus proche de moi
dans ce qu'il faut bien peser le premier
prix du conservatoire
en comédie classique comédie moderne
étrangères comme comme huster non comme
perrin on a faim on a passé le buteur
rennella même et uster aussi parler
d'avantagé d'avant vous avez plutôt
l'image je suis passé pub c'est pas du
tout un reproche loin de là à vous est
plutôt l'image d'un gentleman acteurs on
dirait vous êtes plutôt proche de cary
grant ou de james stewart que de de niro
de pacino ou ces mecs là quoi oui
peut-être on peut me donner ce style de
rôle et ça me fait plaisir j'aime bien
james stewart mais mais en même temps
c'est plus tellement ce cinéma là qu'on
fait en jouer en france qui est pas
tellement majoritaire il semble à ce
genre de la comédie ne peux pas dire si
ça se retrouve ailleurs chez d'autres
cinéastes mais pas tellement en france
et donc mais en même temps mon désir ça
n'a pas été de rester uniquement dans
une enveloppe ou dans un style ou dans
une image c'était plutôt de me balader
on est quand même dans une fois vous
rêvez d'extravagance vous rêvez le frère
dont césar de bazan dans ruy blas vous
rêvez de shakespeare cirque en fait vous
avez le sentiment
ça vous avez quel âge 52 3 en 53 ça vous
ont comme tant de bien de vous exprimer
c'est peut-être mon échec qui compte
c'est celle en villa way est peut-être
la crédibilité à travers un personnage
si vous êtes très france c'est un peu un
peu provincial qua non sans doute bas je
ne dis pas mais enfin les rôles sont
fait pour qu'on se dépayser qu'on ait
des apparences raidissement voyez pas
que c'est le poids de votre éducation ça
c'est à dire que finalement on n'échappe
pas à son éducation en échoppe s'échappe
pas mais on est acteur justement pour y
échapper et moi ça me gêne pas de me
grimer où ça me gêne pas de même sans
brimer de jouer des choses qui sont à
l'opposé de moi si j'ai choisi ce métier
c'est justement pour ça pouvoir me
libérer et faire des choses tout à fait
une attention autour de vous mais moi
oui
alors mes dents amédée vous le faites
quoi je dirais vous sautez dans deux
films ça dépend si les films sont vus
beaucoup pas mais je le fais de plus en
plus près de l'âge qui me le permet
alors vous travaillez beaucoup truffaut
disais il est comme comme bouquet comme
michel bouquet il répète csn après alors
c'est quoi ce que vous allez savoir
tourner oui c'est ça savez-vous tour
évidemment je le répète avant et je les
joue mais enfin il ya une telle
frustration au cinéma parce qu'ils
évoquant ses fruits c'est elles soient
réunies ont pas ça c'est pas comme le
théâtre
donc évidemment j'avais tendance à les
répéter après mais c'était de prendre ma
première expo
rafik donc après j c est ce que j'ai
bien fait ce que je faisais à réaliser
dans un coin du plateau massaise des
ridicules un truc énorme dépôt pour
conclure il ya une bonne définition de
vous qui a été donné par quelqu'un qu'on
aime tous beaucoup ces gens afin qu'on
aimait malheureux est plus là que jean
louis borie critique du nouvel obs qui
disait dussollier c'est un belmondo qui
aurait lu oui mais enfin écoutez moi je
lis l'équipe attendait pas dire
globalement donne jamais mais non j'ai
lu beaucoup à une certaine période mais
enfin je dis si je dis encore mais
peut-être moins je sais pas c'est
classement on peut en faire plein on
peut faire d'autres ont tellement de
l'opposition voilà donc je remercie en
tous les cas il pourrait être sûr de ne
rien rater
le i know you tube abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu